[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parler brave dobrogea katia bonjour
mickey marc faire toute l'actualité
politique et surtout parlementaire 30
minutes pour cela avec notre invité
julien bargeton bonjour jo et bien nous
sommes ravis de vous accueillir vous
êtes tout nouveau sénateur de paris vous
faites donc votre mandat votre premier
mandat parlementaire vous venez d'être
élu pour la république en marche et vous
êtes jusqu'au 6 octobre le aussi le
premier adjoint aux finances
le 1er mai devant film adjoint aux
finances pas prêt de la de la mère anne
hidalgo on va en parler on revoit
d'abord avec vous le film de la semaine
le budget 2010 8 qui a été présenté au
parlement les ministres ont défendu
leurs mesures sous le feu des questions
la loi antiterroriste débattu à
l'assemblée échanges très animés dans
l'hémicycle et puis du renouvellement
partiellement en tout cas au sénat la
droite même conforte sa position
dominante et on va commencer donc par le
premier budget présenté par le
gouvernement d'edouard philippe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les ministres sont donc venus à
l'assemblée et au sénat défendre le
projet de loi de finances ou les
critiques bien entendu c'est un sujet
signé stéphanie des pierres devant les
députés
le grand oral a duré presque trois
heures le climat est tendu notamment
entre les ministres de l'économie et du
budget et leurs anciens collègues des
républiques bruno lemaire défend la
réduction du déficit public et rappelle
que la france ne respecte plus les
critères européens depuis 2008
quand nicolas sarkozy était président
eric woerth à bercy
tu n'oublieras pas cher eric qu'en 2008
il est à nouveau présent la république
qui est allé au conseil des ministres
des finances à bruxelles
et quitte à les expliquer tous les
ministres des finances que tous ses
engagements européens ça n'avait
absolument aucune importance et qui
n'était pas question que la france les
respecte je te rappelle que nous étions
dans le même gouvernement a d'ailleurs
jeu juste un point tel que tu étais
solidaire avec ces mesures ces
mesures-là et deuxième point il ya eu en
2008 une crise et je souhaite juste dire
que ces crises elle a profondément
influé sur le niveau économique de la
france pour respecter les règles
européennes le gouvernement annonce à 16
milliards d'euros d'économies pour 2018
mais le haut conseil pour les finances
publiques restent sceptiques sur la
réalité de ces économies autre mesure 10
milliards d'euros de baisses d'impôt
d'ici un an
6 pour les entreprises 4 pour les
ménages pour les communistes
elles profiteront surtout aux plus
riches votre projet de budget c'est au
bonheur des riches
c'est un budget sincèrement fait pour
les riches par les riches quand les
français sont appelés à se serrer la
ceinture
même sentiment du côté de la france est
soumise
ça fait 30 ans qu'on nous assure nous
sort ça c'est une politique qui sévit à
peu près partout en europe et qui fait
qu' il n'y a pas d'investissement il ya
beaucoup de chômage et il ya beaucoup de
revenus pour les dividendes
donc voilà je pense que ça c'est le
premier pan et le deuxième pont c'est
d'obéir à berlin et bruxelles pour que
la france applique une politique
d'austérité qui va là aussi est très
mauvais pour nos concitoyens les députés
de la commission des finances débattront
en détail du budget 2018
le 11 octobre prochain je démarre jetons
vous entendez les critiques un budget
pour les riches
le projet de budget qui a été présentée
marque un tournant significatif
d'abord c'est la première fois qu'il ya
une présentation sur cinq ans ce qui
donne de la visibilité et de la
crédibilité à l'action gouvernementale
c'était attendu
cette forme aussi de stabilité fiscale
de stabilité dans les mesures qui a
tendu par les ménages comme iliad
entreprises et évolutive pour les riches
c'est aussi l'effet des symboles c'est
aussi un budget qui est sincère parce
que les inscriptions budgétaires sont
remises à niveau il n'ya plus les sous
inscriptions que nous avions connu et
qui avait été très critiquée par la cour
des comptes notamment et puis c'est un
budget qui prévoit des économies telles
que le gouvernement les avait annoncé
donc c'est un budget qui est clair et
cohérent sur les notamment j'entends la
critique sur la partie fiscale mais je
ne la partage pas c'est un budget pour
l'investissement notamment la
pérennisation du crédit aux entreprises
sous forme de baisse des cotisations
c'est aussi un budget pour les classes
moyennes et pour les classes populaires
je vous rappellerai par exemple qu'il y
à une hausse des minima sociaux je pense
au minimum vieillesse ou à l'allocation
handicapé et il y à aussi la réduction
de la taxe d'habitation et la réduction
des cotisations sociales qui vont
profiter massivement mais aux classes
moyennes c'est vrai mais il ya aussi des
coups de rabot sur les allocations les
apl suppression des contrats aidés
comment lancer un élu socialiste
on a parlé des apl on n'a pas parlé du
fait que le rsa avait été augmentée de
10 euros par exemple donc il faut
regarder les mesures dans son ensemble
quant aux mesures en faveur des
entreprises
elles sont là pour permettre
l'investissement je pense qu'il est
important que l'épargné des français
soit tourné davantage vers
l'investissement c'est effectivement
cette mesure phare sur le l'impôt sur
l'épargné notamment et puis qui mit
enfin qui mit à 39 cents un niveau à peu
près enfin le même pour tout le monde et
qui est extrêmement clair c'est à dire
qui permettra aussi d'investir ou sur
lui et celles qui tournent et derrière
il y aller il faut qu'ils nous avons
aussi des actionnaires oui c'est que les
français se sont détournés des actions
depuis 25 ans à peu près notamment au
profit des non résidents qui sont passés
à 45% de la détention de la détention
des actions dans le cac 40 est donc et
il est aussi important que nous
puissions défendre la cantonnant dans
les investisse parce que vous inciter à
l'investissement encore faut-il qu'il y
ait un retour sur l'investissement oui
mais je veux dire on parle toujours de
du coup de l'allégement de l'isf
on ne parle pas du coût de son maintien
et du fait que nous avons aussi besoin
que des personnes ne quitte pas le
territoire parce que ces personnes qui
sont certes aisée elle paye aussi par
ailleurs de la csg et de l'impôt sur
leurs revenus des taxes foncières de la
tva etc etc
il ya donc beaucoup de rentrer autres
qui sont liées sur sur ces personnes nar
notant que votre devoir d'explication
aujourd'hui pour pour ce budget
simplement quand on entend le parti
socialiste qui est assez proche quand
même été membre pourquoi est ce que on
est dans ces attaques
geder frontale quand on parle de budget
de riches quand on prend l'exemple savez
des yachts des voitures de luxe qui vont
être un exemple de dsf
par exemple ce sont des symboles très
fort entre n'y ait pas qu'il ya une
faute peut-être de communication de la
part du gouvernement sur première chose
le parti socialiste les jeux y en a et
est membre très longtemps et j'ai
beaucoup d'attachement pour les
militants qui sont des gens sincères
engagé investi j'ai beaucoup d'amis je
deviens qu'elles ont bougé j'ai gardé
beaucoup d'amis je pense que dans sa
stratégie
le parti socialiste a tendance parfois
se complaire dans la facilité de
l'opposition quand il est en gestion il
a du mal à se mettre d'accord entre la
partie je dirais plus gestionnaire et la
partie des frondeurs ont la vue et donc
pour
le parti socialiste il ya une certaine
facilité à être dans la la critique
nationale tandis qu'à l'est dans
l'opposition permanente
j'entends cette remarque notamment sur
vous les avez évoqué les signes
extérieurs de richesse
leleu parle le parlement va travailler
le gouvernement à déposer une copie
moi j'entends travailler sur ces sujets
là avec et elle modifié qui arrive à
modifier les jeux c'est bien monsieur
quand on quitte à modifier faut je crois
à réfléchir à la réintégration des
signes extérieurs de richesse dans
l'assiette de liesse à vous y est
favorable
je suis favorable à ce que ses traits à
ce que cette réflexion soit lancé et ma
titre personnel je pense qu'en effet un
signal qui serait de la réintégration
ils résident dans le bon sens mais
encore une fois c'est d'abord le groupe
qui doit en discuter c'est le travail
avec le gouvernement vous savez moi je
suis pour la co élaboration la
co-construction il faut être ni
frondeurs ni godillots il faut qu'on
construit en tout cas donc le budget
sera examiné d'abord à l'assemblée il va
ensuite passer au sénat il ya des
chances qu'ils soient largement amendé
les débats vont être intéressants les
débats vont être très intéressante si je
si je peux je souhaite intégrer la
commission des finances n'est pas encore
fait mais les débats vont être
effectivement vivre je souhaite que le
sénat soit vraiment la chambre des
territoires et la chance du pluralisme
politique
l'assemblée nationale et la chambre du
fait majoritaire c'est normal a le
dernier mot notamment sur le budget et
donc le sénat peut être effectivement
travailler sur ces sujets là mais sur ce
budget nous tenons quand même que c'est
un budget aussi qui va permettre de
donner beaucoup de pouvoir d'achat aux
classes moyennes mais l'usagé populaire
les députés à julien bargeton aussi
achevé cette semaine l'examen du projet
de loi qui autorise les perquisitions
des assignations à résidence c'était
l'autre grand thème la loi
antiterroriste en débat au parlement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ce débat a été marqué par certaines
passes d'armes entre les différents
groupes écouter notamment cet échange
qui a eu lieu dans l'hémicycle entre
manuel valls l'ancien premier ministre
face à alexis corbière de la france
insoumise écoutez nous islamo gauchiste
mais quel mépris
c'est d'ailleurs assez peu honorable que
certains utilisent cette qualification
contre nous y compris vous monsieur
valls vous voyez vous parlez comme le
front national c'est pas glorieux
c'est pas glorieux oui oui vous parlez
comme le front national quand il s'agit
de nous taper dessus monsieur valls il y
a le débat de fond qui est la lutte
contre le radicalisme et ceux qui a
derrière et c'est là monsieur corbières
au moi je continuerai à dénoncer vos
prises de position
vos alliances les liens avec des
indigènes de la république et avec tous
ceux qui aujourd'hui dans les quartiers
représentent un vrai danger parce que
précisément derrière cela il y as we
l'islamisme radical et l'islam politique
débat très tendu ça vous a surpris cette
cet échange entre le premier ministre et
le poids d'une joute oratoire bon qui
font partie du jeu aussi des assemblées
parlementaires surtout regarder le fond
du dossier cette loi est une loi d'
équilibre qui permet de protéger les
français et en même temps de lutter
contre la menace terroriste
le l'état d'urgence avec les critiques
et sa reconduction donc notamment
systématique
il est à mon avis intéressant d'essayer
de voir comment intégrer une marty des
mesures seulement une partie d'ailleurs
des mesures de l'état d'urgence dans le
droit commun sous le contrôle du juge et
du parlement afin d' un fois améliorer
la sécurité des français parce que la
menace terroriste est toujours là les le
pouls et ozzy la sécurité devient sur
elle et les forces d'assurer les forces
le gouvernement a annoncé beaucoup de
recrutements il pour les forces de
police et de gendarmerie
je note d'ailleurs que ceux qui
critiquent notamment en droite avaient
été ceux qui avaient déshabillé les
forces de police et qui avait la baisser
la garde
notamment en réduisant massivement des
effectifs de police où le gouvernement
sarkozy fillon
il ya aussi des critiques alors varier
sur sur des points
divers notamment le contrôle élargis qui
rendu possible aux frontières là ça fait
ça provoque beaucoup de polémiques
certains y voient aussi une manière
d'endiguer l'immigration clandestine aux
frontières porte sur la loi sur le
l'antiterrorisme donc c'est faux quand
j'entends dire que ça élargit énormément
le chant c'est une loi qui est consacré
d'ailleurs contrairement état d'urgence
consacrée aux chants de la lutte contre
le terrorisme et donc les mesures sont
restreintes à l'application 2 dans ce
cadre là je crois que c'est quand même
très important de le souligner par
ailleurs j'ai noté que certains
parlementaires voulaient faire des
propositions notamment sur l'évaluation
de la loi son contrôle etc
je crois que c'est une proposition
notamment du modem 6 g
si j'ai écouté les débats hier je pense
que ce sont des propositions vive 9,1
des propositions à celle ci juge avoir
une force de suivi des parlementaires
sur l'application de la loi
mais tant dans son contenu contestation
sur l'état de droit mais dans son
contenu je la partage
mais où franchement quand quand on se
regarde on se désole parfois quand on se
compare on se console
où est la difficulté est ce que les
libertés des français ont été réduites
un seul instant dans la période
précédente
est ce que la liberté de circulation de
manifester voyez de créer que certaines
encore exactement qu'un canapé au fait
de jeu diront certains critiques de
cette loi sont par ailleurs des
thuriféraires du régime qui sont
extrêmement contestable du point de vue
des libertés
pardonnez moi de le dire notamment en ce
qui concerne la france insoumise pour le
régime de monsieur maduro au venezuela
et donc quand j'entends le soutien à ces
régimes là est par ailleurs des
critiques qui me paraissent infondées
sur un état de droit une démocratie
comme la france où nous avons eu toutes
les manifestations contre la loi travail
pendant cet état d'urgence donc je crois
qu'il faut être raisonnable nos libertés
ne sont pas menacés le juge contrôlera
une partie des mesures et nous devons
équilibrer
allawi si vous êtes donc d'accord avec
manuel valls quand il dit que la france
soumise est un certain regard dangereuse
pour les quartiers c'est exactement ce
qu'il a dit moi je pense si vous voulez
que là la france insoumis je ne sais pas
si la france insoumise et dangereuse jeu
pense qu'elle tient un discours parfois
dangereux notamment vis-à-vis de la
sécurité des français
alors on va revenir bien évidemment sur
une autre actualité qui a marqué la
semaine c'est ce sont des élections
sénatoriales
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bilan de ces élections la droite sort
renforcé le ps arrive un petit peu quand
même à résister et la république en
marche fait un petit peu moins que prévu
julien bargeton voit sa douceur la
république en marche ne sera pas la
deuxième force politique du sénat comme
l'espérait cet été françois patriat le
président du groupe depuis il avait revu
ses ambitions à la baisse pour tabler
sur 20 30 sénateurs les résultats lui
ont donné raison
et alors que gérard larcher évoque la
victoire d'un contre-pouvoir
parlementaire ce n'est pas le rôle du
sénat d'être un conte un contre-pouvoir
le rôle du sénat
je ne partage pas cette idée d'un
contre-pouvoir aujourd'hui je crois que
la france a besoin du maximum de force
pour pouvoir se transformer et que
l'idée d'un contre-pouvoir n'est pas
vraiment très efficace pour l'avenir de
notre pays aujourd'hui
un coup d'arrêt pour la république en
marche dont le groupe au sénat comptera
moins de sénateur que lors de sa
création
car ce dimanche c'est bel et bien la
prime au sortant qui a payé
à l'image de la droite qui conforte sa
majorité vous savez les grands électeurs
ils vivent au milieu de la population et
le résultat ce soir c'est le reflet
particulier pour une élection données
d'une sorte finalement de perte de
confiance vis-à-vis de l'exécutif
et puis c'est rajouter les maladresses
toutes les maladresses depuis deux mois
qui ont confiné parfois au mépris
vis-à-vis des élus locaux la plus grande
victoire elle sans aucun doute celle des
centristes qui enregistrent leur plus
grande progression c'est un très beau
succès pour la majorité pour le groupe
de l'union centriste et je crois que ça
permet
de continuer le travail qui est fait
soit présence de jarrat marchés depuis
maintenant trois ans à gauche les
socialistes ont résisté malgré leurs
divisions
l'heure est au soulagement nous serons
le deuxième groupe
c'était un objectif et c'est très
important symboliquement politiquement
je suis très fier de pouvoir porter le
combat d'une opposition socialiste au
gouvernement
à gauche toujours les communistes ont
réussi à conserver un groupe avec plus
de dix sénateurs dont qui s'est passé
quelque chose
parmi notamment les électeurs de gauche
de cette élection qui ont souhaité je
lis bien l'entrée de notre groupe et je
pense que nous serons le coeur de
l'opposition à emmanuel macron dans le
dos et n'a aucun élu en revanche pour le
front national
alors que les écologistes espèrent
pouvoir recréer un groupe s'il
équilibres politiques au sénat reste
inchangé le grand jeu des ralliements va
maintenant commencer
combien d'élus centristes se
rapprocheront des macros nist y
aura-t-il un groupe d constructif au
sénat les socialistes réussiront ils à
maintenir une ligne commune
les tractations ne font que commencer
alors je viens part je trouve 22 députés
de la république en marche finalement
ccc des sénateurs bon bah c'est moi que
ce que vous pouviez espérer mais donc
maintenant le grand marché des
ralliements et est ouvert qu'est ce que
vous espérez et avec qui surtout vous
pourriez vous ralliez pour peser ces
élections sénatoriales était redoutable
pour la république en marche
nous n'avions pas de grands électeurs et
nous avons quand même décidé d'y aller
vous avez noté d'ailleurs que la france
insoumise a fait un choix différent
puisque confrontés à la même absence de
grands électeurs
elle a décidé de ne pas présenter de
candidat nous avions eu un tort c'est de
ne pas gagner les élections municipales
de 2014 mais en même temps nous
n'existions pas donc on a dû aller
convaincre des grands électeurs qui
avaient rejoint la démarche de la
majorité présidentielle il est vrai que
les résultats constants le résultat est
inférieur à certaines espérances mais
parce qu'il faut toujours essayer de
convaincre davantage pour autant nous
sommes le groupe coeur de la majorité
présidentielle qui doit être à l'origine
de la construction de majorité de projet
au sénat je pense que sur les
ordonnances relatives au dialogue social
sur le budget sur la loi de sécurité
intérieure dont nous avons parlé nous
sommes à même d'essayer de porter des
consensus le plus large possible pour
qu'on prenne heures
donc allez voir les différents groupes
politiques qui composent de senna
discuté de voitures voilà sur ce texte
on peut trouver une majorité
comment ça va se passer exactement moi
on va essayer il faut toujours essayer
de gratter un peu des casques bleus du
cénacle de concerter de convaincre nous
sommes le groupe qui se reconnaît dans
la majorité présidentielle et l'action
du gouvernement entièrement mais pour
autant nous sommes là aussi pour
s'ouvrir et pour convaincre sur tel et
tel projet de du bienfait des mesures
que nous défendons et donc oui
construire des majorités de projets et
notamment pour réviser les institutions
le sénat doit-il être facteur de blocage
le sénat doit-il être une chambre
d'empêchement d'un puissant tu mens je
ne crois pas que les français souhaitent
que le sénat soit finalement quelque
chose qui cloche là vous êtes en train
de dire que aujourd'hui tel qu'il est
avec cette majorité sénatoriale de
droite
il bloque des institutions non je ne
crois pas je pense que c'est le risque
c'est à dire que nous notre notre
volonté c'est de ces d'éviter cela je ne
crois pas moi je ne prête de mauvaises
solutions intelligentes volume attention
je ne fais de procès d'intention à
personne mais ce que je pensais dans
l'attitude préalable je crois pas que
les français souhaitent un sénat qui
soit une chambre qui bloquerait epide
veulent plutôt un sénat qui co construit
vous avez vu le sondage et lab qui a été
réalisé 19 % des français trouvent que
le sénat n'est pas assez représentatifs
57% des français souhaitent qu'il soit
modernisée mais en même temps les
français dans ce sondage sont attachés
au bicaméralisme donc et ne veulent pas
sa disparition a une à une large
majorité
donc je crois que nous avons là le
chemin pour essayer de régler le sénat
parmi les grands chantiers il ya aussi
la future réforme constitutionnelle mais
pour ça si on passe par le parlement il
faut réunir une majorité des trois
cinquièmes des membres du parlement
sénateurs et députés pour l'instant on
ne sait pas gagner ça dépendra de la
façon dont le texte est construit et co
élaborés il n'est jamais interdit
d'essayer de convaincre au maximum si
nous pensons que cette réforme est juste
qu'elle est équilibrée
alors il n'y a pas de raison que les
autres
coupe ne se retourne pas vers nous et
refusent de travailler il faut il faut
essayer de convaincre moi je sais que
parfois les parties les organisations
politiques se complaisent dans une forme
d'opposition
je suis je suis toujours j'ai toujours
porté l'optimisme de la volonté il ya
parfois le pessimisme de la raison mais
il ya toujours l'optimisme de la volonté
qui est là vous êtes 22 aujourd'hui dans
le groupe la république en marche au
sénat demain peut-être combien est-ce
que vous avez eu des signes d après des
appels du pied
comment je ne sais pas je ne sais pas et
je sais ce que je dis c'est que ce
groupe est un groupe ouvert
c'est un groupe qui a vocation à
accueillir toutes celles et tous ceux
qui se reconnaissent dans l'action de la
majorité présidentielle et qui veulent
transfor transformer le pays je ne vais
pas vous donner un deux chiffres
j'espère que nous serons le maximum
j'entends je comprends que certains
disent on est d'accord avec ça mais pas
de corps avec tout ça dépend des moments
je pense moi dans la vie politique il
faut plutôt essayer de faire preuve de
clarté c'est ma il faut éviter les
confusions ensuite chacun est libre
c'est le rôle d'une assemblée comme le
sénat deux évidemment organiser les
débats dans la plus grande liberté
on continue julien bargeton a parlé un
peu plus de vous à présent avec notre
partenaire du figaro.fr que nous
accueillons maintenant
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour 4 bonjour michael veut vivre
julien bargeton entendu vos réticences
tout à l'heure sur la sortie des biens
de luxe de l'isf
certains ex socialiste comme vous julien
bargeton vont plus loin et prédisent
déjà l'éclatement de la majorité
brigitte bourguignon qui est député en
marche dit au fur et à mesure que l'on
va rentrer dans les vrais débats
politiques on va perdre des députés qui
juge que la majorité pense trop à droite
ou trop à gauche
est ce que vous partagez vous ces
craintes je ne partage pas ce pessimisme
sur l'avenir de la république en marche
c'est un mouvement qui s'appuie sur
d'anciens socialistes il est vrai comme
moi qui l'ont rejoint sur un accord avec
le modem qui a été décisif avec françois
bayroux et puis dlr constructif
notamment au moment des législatives qui
ont rejoint cette volonté de transformer
le pays accompagné de la société civile
qui s'est retrouvé dans ce souffle
nouveau qui a été le président la
république et d'un mouvement formidable
avec énormément d'adhérence 53 mille
adhérents à paris qui sont toujours là
et donc c'est une heure c'est une c'est
une synthèse c'est que c'est un blog
ensuite ce bloc qui est évidemment qui
vient d'origines diverses
il doit toujours avancer pour ne pas
tomber c'est évidemment un pari c'est un
pari politique contre la rente politique
c'est ça qu'a fait le président de la
république te ment et ça veut dire donc
essayer de dépasser le clivage droite
gauche en se disant on a des origines
différentes on est certains se sentent
plus sociaux démocrates d'autres plus
sociaux libéraux nous sommes tous très
européen nous sommes tous pour la
liberté de création d'entreprendre de
vivre ce qu'il ce qui est ça évidemment
pour le maintenir ça nécessite de faire
un effort sur soi même et c'est
peut-être un parti un parti fort tissu
qui soit un espace de débat où chacun
puisse exprimer ses sensibilités
on a l'impression que le parti justement
peine à exister face à l'exécutif à ça
mais manuel macro est ce qu'il faudrait
justement un parti fort il faut un
mouvement politique fort qui ne peut pas
être un parti politique traditionnelle
politique les partis politiques ont
échoué et nous
man ont échoué à faire vivre le
collectif des militants et puis ils ont
échoué dans les divisions et les
baronnies c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un
moment comme il faisait semblant de se
mettre d'accord sur certaines choses ont
tout le monde savait qu'on n'était pas
vraiment d'accord on se répartissaient
dans des votes et il y avait des
rapports de force qui fait qu'on ne
savez jamais qui fait qu'on ne savez
jamais où on allait ensuite le mouvement
de la république en marche doit
s'inventer une forme nouvelle
ce qui n'est pas facile c'est une tâche
très difficile il faut donc être à la
fois un mouvement qui à un moment je
pense une forme de leadership une forme
d'incarnation car tout mouvement
politique le mouvement certains patrons
on parle de benjamin griveaux m'ouvre
tout le monde j'ai voulu choquer stoner
est ce que vous savez que je sais que
une préférence et puis tout le monde
adore le jeu du name dropping mais je
vais vous décevoir en y participant pas
met donc à un moment on doit s'incarner
doit trouver une façon de vivre et
surtout de faire vivre les les adhérents
pelez les adhérents ils attendent des
choses différentes
il ya toute une gamme de militantisme il
faut jouer sur toutes les touches du
clavier et il faut mieux faire
correspondre les envies des militants
avec le besoin de fonctionnement d'un
mouvement politique alors vous êtes
sénateur en marche mais vous étiez où
vous êtes encore peut-être pour quelques
jours adjoint aux finances à la mairie
de paris
oui vous allez d'ailleurs quitté votre
mandat c'est obligatoire dont peuvent se
cumuler le 6 octobre ou encore
normalement d'ici 6 oct la maire de
paris en tout cas s'est réjoui de votre
élection comme elle sait ajoute celle de
pierre laurent à paris où des stars ben
bassat communistes écologistes on sent
qu'elle essaye de ménager un peu les
différents pans de sa majorité en vue
des municipales de 2020 est ce que vous
allez vous la soutenir dans cette
bataille il faut déconnecter les enjeux
nous avons vécu une élection nationale
cette élection nationale elle repose sur
sera elle repose sur un mode de scrutin
effectivement indirects dont qui
s'appuie sur les locaux mais il ne faut
pas confondre le mode de scrutin avec
l'objet du scrutin donc moi j'appartiens
à la majorité municipale j'ai été élu en
2014 sur un contrat de mandature qui
s'applique et les parisiens ne
comprendrais pas que finalement d'autres
événements viennent percuter une équipe
qui a été élue ensemble nous avons été
élus sur les mêmes listes avec anne
hidalgo
pour autant il ne vous a pas
schaper que nous n'avons pas fait tout à
fait tout à fait les mêmes choix au
niveau national que nous n'avons pas
tout à fait les mêmes orientations
politiques qui pour le pays il est
concret vidéo 31 août est un cadre pour
vivre ensemble voilà on voulait dire que
cette majorité doit pérenniser mais
peut-être avec une autre tête ça veut
dire quoi personne n'a intérêt à
déstabiliser les collectivités locales
en revanche les personnes qui souhaitent
vivre dans un cadre nouveau doivent
trouver un moyen d'expression au sein de
la majorité municipale pour faire vivre
l'expression de la majorité
présidentielle merci c'était donc la
phrase de fin julien bargeton merci
d'avoir été notre invité merci à tous
merci de film on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine bonne semaine satyam
[Musique]